so I think the way I would like to do
this is I'm gonna ask them each a
question and introduce them and then
I'll turn it over to you guys to ask
questions and some of the questions that
I think came up on the diligence list as
well as from the first half of the class
I think you know we've got some experts
to choose from and I'm going to start
with Jim southern raise your hand Jim so
Jim and I have known each other for 20
plus years I mean a very very long time
when you still had hair Jim was my Jim
was actually my second investor in my
whole life when I raised my first search
fund and since then I have invested in
deals that Jim had and Jim has invested
in deals that I did and he's been on my
board and I've been on his board and
that's all well and good and we've made
money together and we've lost money
together but the best part is that
somewhere along the way the business
relationship became unimportant and it
just became a friendship so I'd like to
introduce Jim as my friend let me ask
you the first question how have you seen
searchers handle this whole issue of
identifying whether a person is a seller
or not so I've seen it handled well and
I've seen seen it handled poorly I think
the I think it's important that you
learn to get a deal flow going but to
get to learn how to get on and off a
deal because it's going to be the
velocity with which you move from deal
to deal that determines kind of the
probability that you're going to get a
business bought in your search some
people will not even go out to visit
someone unless they have revenue and
EBIT da maybe in the form of just a
telephone conversation from the seller
or possibly in the form of financial
statements and only then will he go out
and visit them if he's if they have some
general range of agreement on price that
works pretty well but you need to have a
huge deal flow
which might work for you guys because
you were seeing so many companies if
your deal flow is not so big you're more
likely to handle it poorly and you're
gonna go see people it really won't up
don't want to show you their financial
statements they don't want to talk about
price they tell you about their friend
who got seven times EBIT or something a
couple years ago and you can just end up
spending a lot of time and money and
drying up the rest of your pipeline in
the process thanks rich Kelly rich
started search fund partners what how
many years ago seven years ago and as a
graduate here the business school and
we've actually never met although we've
seen each other's names on the bottom of
documents many many many times and I
think the best thing that speaks towards
rich and search fund partners is the
number of times people say Oh have you
talked to search fund partners they seem
to be on everybody's a list and it's
easy to get on the investor a list when
you have no reputation but after you've
done a lot of deals and had to sort of
conduct yourself both in good deals and
bad deals and tough deals and easy deals
you start to build a reputation for who
you really are and search fund partners
as has endured all that and stayed on
everybody's a-list so it's just a really
a pleasure to have you here which can
you maybe address the issue of to what
extent searchers have been able to
effectively use their investors to gain
credibility when somebody asks
effectively how do I know you can buy
this company yes because anybody worth
their salt is going to look at most
freshly minted MBAs as being there's a
whole bunch of techniques but the first
thing you got to remember is that the
search fund model itself is really
gathering momentum just on its own and
so many many business brokers now are
very familiar with it ten years ago five
years ago that wasn't the case and so
you've kind of you're catching a wave
there that's
it's becoming well-known people
understand the kind of to to search
mechanism websites are so easy to put up
you've got the investors backgrounds I
put a bio in for each one so that
somebody can Google Google on to them
then Google onto all the way through
into the investor pool and then lastly
have a go-to list of two or three
investors that are used to the kind of
requests where they can actually talk
directly to the seller if the seller
wants some verification that there are
people behind this guy we've sent
letters certifying that we are investors
in this thing and we're willing to look
at every deal we never stretch it to say
we're definitely go under than us but
you can get credibility just with a
letter or a phone call and then
oftentimes if that actually evolves into
a meeting because we want to get
involved into due diligence as quickly
as possible if we can and if we can meet
the seller early on and help convince
them that we're real and the money
behind the searcher is real that's right
so when you get a call from a seller or
you're in a meeting with the seller and
you're not committed to the deal how do
you how do you answer that question if
they ask you over the phone or directly
a search fund partners prepared to do
this deal we've been working with this
this team for a year and a half we've
looked at seven deals with them we also
work with ten other searchers we've
invested in every deal that got past a
certain stage in negotiations and not
quite there yet but we follow up with
what we say Raphael Somoza but nobody
calls him that he's everybody calls him
put Cheeto
we met ten years ago probably when 96
when he and a partner jose stella bought
a billboard company in puerto rico and I
think you heard Bill Eagan say or I
quoted bill Eagan is saying that he only
had two kinds of investments those he
had too much of and those he didn't have
enough of and as soon as I invested with
Paquito and his partner
I was on the board there I knew right
away I didn't have enough and then just
certainly turned out to be the case and
since then they've sold their business
and they made a lot of money for people
and now you've been active investors
both in search funds and Direct
Investing the question I had for you is
that the issue of non-competes came up
and I was wondering if you had some
thoughts about how you guys if it all
had to handle non-compete agreements and
non-disclosure agreements actually yes
they wanted to put in one of our
agreements it was actually the Billboard
industry we were trying to buy we ended
up starting actually well that's fine we
want to put a non-compete anything you
can finish healthy we basically we're
very open and frank that's the look
we're looking at this industry we're
going to enter with or without you
ideally we will buy your company but if
we're not able to reach an agreement we
want to let you know that we might bind
up end up buying someone else and thank
God his Lord was president there that
got stricken out eventually when we
started the company he tried suing us
and we basically refer to our old
agreements we said he was tricking that
that was the end of it so I mean that's
that was something that is very
important you never do
ideally their way that I think was Mike
you mentioned their their na
solicitation for employees that's a way
of getting trying to make the solar feel
a little bit more comfortable in terms
of the confidentiality agreements one of
the things we did
and I think this was was building trust
with many of you brought up we always
were the ones bringing that forth they
want after the first meetings that look
if you're interested in discussing this
obviously there will have to be exchange
of information what we propose so that
you feel comfortable is we sign a
confidentiality agreement and that way
you'll be protected and will be
protected and I think that immediately
when we took the first step in saying
that that's sort of lower the defenses
of the seller and okay
by the way just to digress Jim you've
invested in how many deals roughly forty
five search funds probably 23 active and
your estimated IRR is don't know the IRR
it's been about 13 okay so it's a very
good record and Jim will have all these
reasons why he's done so well but the
real reason is he's got a really good
investment committee including his wife
Linda southern so I like to welcome
Linda southern that is the power behind
the throne that's right Robert you are
you're generous with all the information
about the logistics of your search and
how you managed it and your time and so
forth I'm wondering if you would just go
to a completely different place and
maybe comment a little bit should me a
little bit about what it was like
personally and some of the personal
challenges that you face during the
search absolutely
the thing that we sort of realized about
two months into the deal is with gone
through this you know
happy happy stage and all sudden and and
it correlated with you know you finally
deal it's very exciting and then for
some reason or another it doesn't make
the cut and and every deal that you look
at as a search wonder is the deal until
you actually close the deal so every one
of those was that much more important to
us and we were fully emotionally
invested in it we were fortunate that we
had a team so when it came to you know
being lonely I mean I spoke to mark more
than I spoke to my life and and and we
happen to be different cities you know
we talk all the time because you need a
lot
support cold calling is not easy there's
a lot of rejection you have to handle
it's like being in sales all over again
for those who've been in sales if it's
probably a lot more taxing than than we
anticipate the good news is about two
months into it you figure it out and you
just then and so you know going into a
search even if even if I tell you about
it the first two months are going to be
brutal on the on the emotional side it's
just the way it is because it's a very
very solo exercise you mean if you have
a teammate I have not done a search have
just been an investment but we have a
annual gathering of all of our searchers
and all of our company operators in the
first year we did it we had eight
searchers and one guy that had bought a
company so the agenda was obviously
slanted toward tactics for the search
fund the next year seven people had
found businesses and there was still one
guy searching and so we kind of
flip-flop the agenda and started with a
very small program for the talk about
the search thing we never got to the
operational questions because the guys
who had bought businesses and were
facing daily challenges all they wanted
to talk about was the search fund and it
was like a group therapy exercise we
just kind of stood back it was clearly
one of the most emotional times of their
life and this was a group of people who
all done the same thing and they just
wanted to talk I do remember the first
day of my search and it was something
like I got the fun clothes and I really
remember sort of sitting at my desk and
kind of like moving the pencil over
there and then sharpening it again and
waiting for the phone to ring we didn't
have all the software all right so let
me turn it over to you guys and Jason
you you had it what's that yeah exactly
Jason you had a question which I we were
going to put off until this panel
so actually going
to repeat that question you got it so I
I think to to to raise a search fund
spend two years searching and fail to
find a business and close a search fund
down is a feather in your cap
it is not failure if you choose your
investors carefully they knew the risk
they were good they were taking going in
and assuming they've done more than one
search fund they know that they get a
step up on the search dollars and other
deals to compensate them for taking the
search risk and I'd I just can't see why
why I suppose someone might harbor ill
feelings towards you but it doesn't make
any logical sense for them to have that
furthermore outside of the people that
backed you I think you'll find that they
are amazed that you tried that and that
they'll view that as a source of
strength and it'll be quite easy for you
to go back and get into the career path
line that you might have pursued
straight out of business school the
other part of your question was by the
business it depends on how you fail
after you buy if once you buy a business
I think it depends on how you fail if
you failed just doing making bad
judgment calls after bad judgment calls
I think you're up your reputation as an
operator is going to be soiled if you if
you get out there in two or three years
and go to your investor group and say I
think we bought a dog
the company or we we picked the wrong
industry and you choose to get out
before your reputation is sealed in some
other way I think you're probably in
better shape to the correlation to doing
a start-up I don't think there is any
comparison between the risk of doing a
start-up and the risk of raising a
search fund and finding and buying a
business and succeeding in the universe
of companies that I have where I've
actually made an investment in the
acquisition seventy-five percent of them
have had positive outcomes and only a
quarter of them have had I've lost some
or all of the investor money and I just
you know that the startup business is
just maybe it's one in ten or one in 20
that succeed the I think in terms of
failing to find a company many times the
reason why people will fail was simply
not because they didn't do their work or
were incompetent but because they had
the discipline not to do a bad deal and
I think that that shows a lot in the end
if you run through your fund and the
reason why you didn't do was because you
know you couldn't find a suitable target
which is a lot better than buying a
company for the sake of buying a company
both done bad deals in our careers and
had to manage a company that was in
trouble and I think Jim well I know that
Jim would agree with this is that there
are a few things in your business life
that are more miserable than running a
company that you shouldn't have bought
in the first place because there are no
easy exits in a bad in a bad situation
and I was one of the points that both
bill and will Thorndyke made which is
it's not failure to not get it to not
get a deal done in your search fund the
failure is to rush to judgment on a
company to get a deal done because you
think that is that that's the mark of
success and then you've really put
yourself in a in a tough situation I
don't you want to add anything to that
and then rich Jim it's very difficult to
to recognize that your
buying a bad company in a bad industry
at least from the search of understand
point because you're so invested in the
deal and hopefully you've got you're
surrounded by wise and vet wise
directors and investors who will say
wait a minute Jim this is a bad idea
unfortunately for me it was my second
company that was the bad deal and I
think my investor we had a great outcome
in the first one and I think my
investors imbued me with skills and
characteristics and capabilities that I
didn't have and concluded all of us
incorrectly that I could I would succeed
and what most of us thought was a crummy
industry and so you know the less the
only lesson I learned from that is just
look at good industries with the wind at
your back and good solid companies
within those industries you should be
okay rich if you run in a business that
and it turns out to be a failure a whole
lot of how you end up walking away from
that business in terms of your
reputation and I think your momentum
going forward it's how you and your
investors work together do not try to be
a hero and sail through the wall
you know work with your investors make
sure all of the big decisions are made
in conjunction with your investors
because they're part of the deal and
these are small businesses it's kind of
an informal corporate structure and they
shouldn't want you out there flying solo
questions Victor
what's the biggest surprise require the
company managing human capital so we
bought a business that was in the
secondary market away from their large
Metroplex and as a result of that we
inherited a lot of employees were very
very loyal you can imagine that a lot of
these businesses are going to be
lifestyle
operated businesses which means they
work a certain way but the goal isn't
really aggressive growth the goal is
more sort of a social well-being type
community feeling in written
infrastructure and a lot of what we've
been trying to do is been geared more
towards growing the business which
really puts a lot of strain on and
people's work experience in terms of
what we expect from them and and that is
proven to be you know it mostly
Millennials are getting to this issue
but that's proven to be probably the
biggest surprise in terms of what it
takes to get people so you get them on
board but to keep them on board you know
it's a lot of effort so you know all the
hard work on the financial side how the
word work and customer side you can't
forget the hard work of managing your
people and rewarding them and it's
probably one of the few the fewest
attended class in b-school is the one of
amazing people at work which is ironic
what yeah that's been the challenge
I think there's a little bit of what
they've said about being creative in
your search I think we got to the point
where our our deal took us I think
roughly three years I got to the point
where we had looked ours was a
geographic search in Puerto Rico we had
looked under almost every single Rock
for a company that we weren't sure
Indian if it existed down there and we
had looked at the Billboard industry
liked it tried to buy couldn't do it
because of diligence reasons but we had
done a lot of diligence in the industry
talked to a lot of people we liked I
think Jim pointed something out very
which we're strong believers also and
it's been the case in her second time
around picking industries with high
growth and winning your back and we saw
an under managed under developed under
penetrated industry and we began asking
ourselves a simple question if we were
gonna we were gonna buy I think it was
gonna pay ten million dollars for a
company that had been existence for
three years we looked at the industry we
saw was growing very rapidly and we
looked at ourselves and say well why
can't we just start something from
scratch and it's sort of evolved from
there we sort of made the list of things
that we needed to ascertain in terms of
validating the the execution and try to
limit the startup risk of merely an
execution risk we knew there wasn't a
business model risk it was merely could
we go out and execute and the case of
billboards could you get the sites could
you get the permits could you get the
sales and we did proof of concept and
you know we've had a very disciplined
approach to it and probably spend six
months doing that and up to the point
where we realized that we can we felt
comfortable that we could do it but I
think he there also was anything some
people mention it investor communication
we we had sold the investors on the
industry and actually it was funny in a
way that several of them said look why
not start if you can't buy so it was
sort of we all collectively reached the
same conclusion and I think that's
something that I've always told search
funders look if you find an industry
that
you truly are think it's a great
industry and you can't buy in it at
least ask yourself the question can you
start something in it
I think there's been several examples of
that in the search one community it's
not the traditional way and I'm not
advocating that you go that way but you
know it's something that at least you
should have it in the back of your minds
your startup model fit with the capital
structure that is sort of implicit in a
search fund in terms of the amount of
money you need to raise and the way it's
raised so there would be some startups
that the way the capital would flow
would be contrary to a search fund it
was we raised three million dollars it
was staged and I think where the deals
fade the search fund model in the end it
was and we weren't talking about a new
technology we weren't talking about a
new business model I mean nobody
questioned whether you could actually
make money in billboards the question
was could we execute our billboard
business plan in Puerto Rico and you
know so I think that's the reason why it
fit the business model it wasn't
something as we want to do a new
technology startup within the search one
model it was a proven business model so
that poem I think that I shall never see
a billboard lovely as a tree indeed
unless the billboards fall I'll never
see a tree at all so it's very exactly
the second level management how do you
do it fine our business was all about
the founder retiring so you know
building rapport with the management
team was key and you know something we
continue to work and very aggressively
in terms of mistakes you make I think
you know as I described earlier how we
worked our case of work is significantly
faster than most people's and it took us
a while to slow down to their pace
because you know you have to realize if
you don't adapt to the business you are
not going to let the business sort of
welcome you and grow with you so it's
more of you adapting to the business and
then from that point shifting then
really coming in and pulling the
business because then you're going to be
working the law most of us here are cost
in to working with very similarly minded
people with very similar work ethics
very similar intellect etc and it's very
different when you go to either a
startup company in the industry that we
chose or acquiring a company well you
have to realize that not everyone it's
like you and not everyone can work at
the pace that you do not everyone will
answer an email at 10 o'clock at night
now not everyone will put in the time
that you normally put in so I mean that
for us was a big shock and something
that gets some time to get adjusted to
and you have to be careful not to push
so far so fast then you'll make the
system collapse within the 18 months
you're probably going to have an
entirely different team because you just
weren't able to get those folks up to
the level that you want to
there may be one keeper in the sales
department that is gone all the
relationships but it's inevitably taking
it to the level you want to get it to
this can require almost a complete
changeover and your question is how to
do it gracefully and honestly I mean how
do you position yourself at the very
beginning okay you tell them why you're
company you know why you bought the
business and you tell them what your
your vision is for the company and and I
think everybody realizes that this you
make sure everybody realizes that this
is our vision today and everything so
what we did is we showed up we had a
communication plan for transitioning and
you know we spoke to we had
communication going to the customers we
had things that the seller would say to
the customers say to the employees and
then we flew that same descend the next
day to meet and sort of introduce
ourselves and and ultimately what we
told everyone was everything we've
learned about the business we're gonna
throw out the window and we're gonna
meet with every single one of you to
learn it all over again and that's what
we did so we went on the 90 day plan
where we pretty much re-explore the
entire company and came up with a list
of 130 or so critical initiatives that
were 95% through a year later so to go
while to get to them but that's how we
approached it
so so I my rule of thumb is don't waste
time on the non-believers if they've got
unreasonable price expectations your job
is to have a deal a pipeline of deals to
just go on to the next deal and maybe
you dance around with them you know one
song but if it doesn't go someplace
after that just drop them nicely and but
you might call them back in six months
or three months but get your deal flow
velocity up and get on to the next deal
we did two times where you think you
want to be you can handle that with
structure so that's not a problem but if
it's beyond that then then it is tougher
to do right
I happen to awesome one deal which is
proprietary and I'll buy it so the
founder the founder was actually my
neighbor's son and we spoke to my
buddy's company and the management's he
found out that he was interested in
exiting and they bought it from him
that's a question that I would always
ask in an auction situation is if
management is bidding and if management
is bidding I think that you have to
recognize that you maybe just pricing
the deal for somebody else and that they
have a huge advantage over you so Matt
or Mike a lot of investors search fund
investors agonize over meeting a
prospective search funder and they call
people and say what do you think about
this guy and her gal and and they end up
doing one or two you know back in one or
two searches a year I don't see how in a
45-minute meeting with you or anybody
else or maybe even two 45 minute
meetings over the course of two or three
weeks that I can decide that you're not
a winner and I what I can do is I can
pick up on it is there anything about
you that makes me feel uncomfortable
with your integrity are there anything
of any things about your terms that
would indicate that you're pushing the
envelope like you're going to pay
yourself a hundred and forty thousand
dollars a year and you want convertible
preferred in the fund final structure
and you know stuff like that
I can look for those things but but
basically Who am I to say you're not
going to be a great success and I've
always been pleasantly surprised and so
you've invested in the percentage of the
search buttons that you've invested in
that have it that come to you eventually
for a deal whether it's real capital
what percent of those deals do you think
you do I think it's probably around 65%
to 70% you were smiling at some point in
that answer
first of all answering that question we
we've invested so far in every deal that
has actually made it to our desk that
was a real deal we don't think that's
entirely coincidental because we're
pretty active in the search stage and if
somebody's going to place we don't we
aren't comfortable when we signal that
but yeah the other thing I was just
smiling about I was thinking that when
we first started doing this full-time it
started meeting a lot of searchers we
would agonize like Jim was saying about
Jesus this way this thing pretty quickly
we got to the point we're realizing that
serendipity is just a huge factor in
this and we got comfortable with that
there is something to that and it's why
it's a valuable thing for investors to
have that option allottee it's like I
I'm investing in you because you're
going to work hard and I'm gonna get to
see what you produce in two years and
then I can decide whether I'm going to
put serious money in the deal I'm gonna
know you and then the other thing that
there's a serial investor who's done a
lot of these over 25 years and he's
tried to be incredibly systematic about
trying to predict whether or not
somebody has what it takes to be
successful or not and he's he has the
searchers do a battery of tests and
they're these kind of myers-briggs test
he abandoned ship a couple years ago
he's like there's no correlation
first step of that one we followed a
fairly structure approach for that given
we we thought about industries that we
wanted to target and we tried to have
different people with different
backgrounds in our in our investor base
so we wanted to have operators we wanted
to have people with distribution
expertise or manufacturing expertise we
wanted to have entrepreneurs we wanted
to have private equity guys ideally so
that each one would contribute something
differently to the mix so that's one 2
in terms of leveraging them
I think the quarterly reports at least
for me as an investor now and also
thinking about when I did this they were
a way of letting people know what we
were looking at in such a way that I
could try to elicit response in terms of
yes I know that industry will be careful
with XYZ or you should talk to my friend
Peter in X company and I think that's a
that that for us was really helpful and
I think it's very helpful for people who
do it if you're able to leverage your
investor base in terms of deals that
they've done context that they have
introductions that they can provide
pitfalls valuations I mean a number of
different things that they can be really
helpful with secondly said the one thing
we also did is we picked people who we
knew could help us post acquisition from
a leadership standpoint so one of our
smaller investors is actually someone
who was the CEO for 30 years happened to
mentor other CEOs in that time period
and and we and he told us you know I
can't do a million dollars but I'd be
interested in doing something small and
we told them what we really wanted from
him was the ability to keep him engaged
and and to be able to tap into his his
knowledge on the operation side and he's
on our board today
the result of that so it's really
absolutely how you manage it you need to
try to hypothetically think about what
their possible depth of pockets is yeah
these days it's a different world than
it was four or five years ago now
everybody needs deep pockets because the
capital markets are so stretched you
should actually consider your search
fund group and it's your first line of
investors and then you should have a
second line of investors that you are
almost certain will participate but you
want to have people that can write
bigger checks in your fund as long if
there's a
oh we were targeted in what we're
looking for
sticky be to be tapped transactional
forgiving businesses meaning you know I
lose one client I don't go belly-up as a
result of it and so ironically actually
every company we looked at had
underlying a technology play where we
could add value by capturing
efficiencies based on what we could boot
strap ourselves but there were all
beauty we translational attack companies
and we've had all these ideas about how
to make that resilient over time the
reality is you're so busy that you don't
get to it at all I mean you know the
data is in spreadsheets I had to get to
a different computer to get them all put
together what we can it's there but the
other thing you have to keep in mind is
people move right so probably 75% of
those contacts are no longer valid
because those were accumulated in 2007
they've all changed jobs now that's just
the reality of it
you want both of them in the mix we have
both of them in the mix it's important
that you have both of them in the mix
otherwise you're gonna have a tough time
I guess in talking to the search funders
that I'm search fund entrepreneurs that
I'm invested in there's kind of a common
theme that they're surprised at how
little help they get from their
investors and when you think about it if
if search fund egg calls me about a
really great niche in the widget
industry widget service industry if I
then relay that conversation to search
fund B I am dead meat so I so I can't I
can't be a funnel of information for
starters another another type of
investor is just really busy and he
camps that he can't stop and take every
phone call and also investors by and
large or not deal sources just they're
just not they don't have a source of
deals coming through their shop that
they can give to you because they act on
themselves whether your investor was the
richest man in the world or you know
immortal with 50 million dollars you
want you're sort of starting with a
situation where you want the search fund
piece of their investment pie to
probably be in the 5 to 20 percent
category of their total investments and
then within that maybe they have 5 to 20
search fund investments so I would say
that your problem is not that you're
going to reach their upper limit with
your search fund because if they're
investing 20 or 30 thousand dollars in
the search fund they're they're hoping
that you bring a deal that allows them
to put three hundred thousand or five
hundred thousand dollars of capital work
so that search fund investment is is is
almost insignificant to any of the
search fund investors they're just
thinking about the option and it's not
an irrational thing for them to
completely ignore you for 24 months
until you
bring a deal because they don't have
anything at work yet exactly we really
pride ourselves in truth be told we just
don't get it the same way you do because
it's a digital world for you you're a
zero one option and we've got many many
options and I might encourage you to go
do something that's got a little wild
hair up it because to me that adds to my
portfolio too you would put you out on
the edge living dangerously and so a
Cheeto why don't you take that since
you're on the investor side now I think
it varies by who you talk to but I think
that part of the key here if you're a
new search fund or I think you need to
start looking outside of the traditional
sources of a capital just because
there's so many of them that several or
many people already tapped out or have a
lot of active searches going on right
now so I think it'd be wise to try to
broaden the scope and try to grow the
investor base that looks at these types
of deals but we're seeing a lot of
increased interest from a lot of people
who want to do this on our end we've
we've tapered down a little bit this
year simply because we're also doing a
start-up and we're self funding that and
we have a lot of active searches but you
know we know of other people that are
still very active and and are you know
doing as much as before I mean I think
there's a mix of I don't know if you
agree with that but the pie investors
investors has probably expanded by a
factor of of 10 in the last two years
there used to be 20 kind of known
quantities in search fund investing and
there's now somebody harvested the
websites of all
church funds about nine months ago and I
think the number then was one 160 but
it's probably 200 or 250 by now they're
just plenty of investors out there and
as long as you choose them well I think
you can just ignore this shortage of
capital that you're hearing about so a
Cheeto traveled from San Juan Puerto
Rico and Roberts here from Dallas and
Jim is a legal resident of New Hampshire
because there's no state income taxes as
we traveled from New Hampshire and rich
cowboy rich traveled down the street
that's a lot of effort that the four
people here made to be with you today so
please thank